okay I want to do a quick video on um
well it might not be that quick because
this takes a little while to explain but
a video on explaining
tooling and and setting of tools
and doing various things on this machine
because I've had quite a few questions
about that and
there must be people that are using this
control or this similar type machine and
they want to know about this might not
be so much a video for the general
audience because it's going to be more
kind of technical in nature
on the various things on Machining
and setting up tool offsets and things
like that
but but this machine I'll answer this
question because I've had this question
to begin with this amazec integrix
e650h machine
so this is classified as what you might
call a mill turn machine
where it does milling and turning all in
the same operation
it's more of a milling machine than a
turning machine though people get this
kind of backwards and a lot of people do
a lot of turning on this machine without
Milling of this type of machine I should
say and it's not really the most
efficient thing to do with this kind of
a machine
but anyway the the focus of this video
is going to be more on On Tools tooling
you know and how they mount in the
spindle and how you touch them off and
how you set various tools to do
different kinds of operations
now I've changed to this tool here which
is a
I don't know if you can see that very
well
let me jog it back here a little bit
and over
closer
[Music]
now this tool is a um OD turning tool is
the way it's set up in the machine
although it can do a lot of different
things it just depends on how it's
mounted and configured in the tool setup
on the machine
in fact let's talk about that to begin
with
the the mazek integrix
type of machines or there's other brands
you know like doosan you know more Seiki
whatever
um but they all do basically the same
thing they Orient the tool and clamp it
for a turning tool and of course a
Milling tool can rotate like on a milli
machine
but the way these machines do that or
the way this machine does it in
particular
excuse me is it has a um
a coupling in here
curve it coupling they call it which is
a
a disc with with teeth on it that are
sort of like almost like gear teeth
coarse gear teeth that stick out on both
sides on this machine and then they have
um two kind of
I don't know what how you describe these
like like uh ring like hydraulic Pistons
that engage this
coupling or this disc
with the teeth on it that have mating
teeth that engage it so
when it clamps that for a turning tool
it takes the force into that instead of
the force being transmitted into the
spindle bearings of the Milling spindle
and this coupling can this machine has
what they call a flex tool option
which means that it can index the um
index and clamp the tool every 15
degrees of rotation of the of the
spindle
normally
you mostly clamp the tool in this
orientation or the other for turning
and so they they um in the manual tool
setup if I go over here to the control
and I push the the machine button here
and this and I get this display
and I push spindle
and I can unclamp this tool right now
the tool is oriented and clamped because
this is
um enabled the clamp thing but if I
disable that now I can rotate the tool
freely as if it was a Milling tool
and uh
this tool is set up to orient
in what they call the 180 degree
orientation and then the other
orientation for most turning tools is
that orientation the normal in this case
it's normal in 180 is kind of a
arbitrary term because you can set these
tools up in various different ways if
you have a
a Sandvik for instance boring bar with a
serrated
mounting for the head you can mount the
head either direction and so you could
have it Orient in either direction so
to turn the direction you want to turn
if you will so it that that really
doesn't matter but what it does come
into play is when you have it oriented
in the
the normal orientation when you take the
tool in and out of the spindle
the
the capto taper has this little key and
this hole in it and on this machine
when it's oriented normal they call it
that always faces towards the back of
the machine so you know how to put the
tool in the spindle
like that and clamp it with the draw bar
which I can do manually on this this um
page if you will of the control that can
manually clamp and unclamp it by
selecting these keys this is a manual
operation normally you don't do the any
of this when you're running the machine
it's I'm just doing it manually right
now so so that direction is the normal
orientation of this tool and then I
would clamp it
here so that clamped that coupling in
here
and now it's solidly mounted so it can't
rotate and the force is directed through
that coupling into the spindle head not
through the bearings or anything like
that of the Milling spindle
now I don't know how they did this but
there's um there's two like ring
cylinders hydraulic cylinders that clamp
onto this curvedic coupling disc if you
will in here and however they've made
that I don't know how they did it but it
does not move the spindle it doesn't
shift it
in any direction when it clamps and
unclamps or it's so small you don't
really have to worry about it I'm not
sure how they achieve that
Precision but but it's really quite
precise and it doesn't shift this you
might think well if they're just
clamping into the spindle it would shift
the spindle back and forth you know with
the preload of the bearings would give
and and but it doesn't do that somehow
they've made it work that way I'm not
sure how they did that
but it does work really nicely like that
so now this tool is clamped in a turning
setup
but if we go to the yeah let me see
there's a lot of things to explain here
as I'm trying to figure out how to do
this we go to the tool setup
and I'm going to scroll down to that
tool which is the highlighted tool
here
and a cursor over so I transfer over to
this side of the screen if you if you
you can I don't know if you can see that
in the video but this purple little
purple frame around the Box on the on
the display moves back and forth if you
select this toggle button down here
and you'll notice that this
this tool a turning tool has what they
call an A and A B Dimension the a
dimension
is the length
from the gauge face of the spindle
up to the end of the tool and the V
Dimension here which is this entry over
here is from the center line of the
spindle up
like this so you would basically
visualize if you had this Center Line of
this spindle up with the tip of this
Cutting Edge
that you would move back and down to get
to your A and B dimension
so in this direction it's a positive
number because you're moving into
positive Z Direction and in this
direction it's a negative number because
you're coming from here with the center
line down
in the X direction if that makes kind of
sense so that b dimension for a turning
tool facing this way is negative
and the Z is always positive it's the
length of the tool
and that's very similar to a Milling
tool too the Milling tool is on Center
Line so there's no
there's no um well let me find a million
tool like there's here's an End Mill and
there's no A and B
on the offset of a Milling tool it's
just
the um this this is a Milling tool they
show a lathe tool in the same picture
but and it's only the length that
matters on a Milling tool
so
if you have um
[Music]
those Dimensions those are pretty easy
to achieve by touching the tool off
then you have to of course have the
orientation
correct and this particular tool is in
the what they call the reverse
orientation and clamp there and on a
lathe setup this always clamps the
spindle the Milling spindle with the
coupling
on this setup for a lathe tool or a
turning tool they call it
on a Milling tool it does not there is a
function on the machine that
if you have a
[Music]
um
how do I explain this if you have
if you have a Milling tool in there that
is not clamped in other words the
spindle can freely rotate it it will not
let you do a turning operation it'll
give an alarm if you have that tool in
the spindle but then you try to do a
turning operation
it won't let you do it now it'll kind of
let you do the reverse of that where you
want to do a Milling operation with a
turning tool like this like I've in the
past I've used this as a fly cutter as a
you know like a Milling ply cutter this
exact tool and it will let you do that
but it kind of doesn't let you do the
reverse because it it knows that it
needs a tool to be clamped
for turning
now there is some functions on these
type of machines that will allow you to
rotate both spindles at once like a
hobby
function or
[Music]
ability and um
forget what they call that other way of
of doing a
where you're using a fly cutter in your
and you're making flats and like a hex
or a square or an octagon or whatever
with a fly cutter and is synchronized to
the spindle
I have to look that up I'll put a put it
on the video a text or something of the
name of it but but uh
this machine doesn't have that option
but this machine does have the hobbing
option which means I could synchronize
the Milling spindle to the c-axis really
it's it's more of the um
c-axis in the and the Milling spindle
rotating in synchronous so you could
Mill a gear teeth if you had the proper
Tooling in the spindle like a hob and
you tip the b-axis at a certain angle
and then you can synchronize that with
the Hobby and uh Mill gears and things
like that the
the other type where you're just using a
fly cutter I think it actually runs the
the Turning spindle with that option but
this machine doesn't have that
so those are the kind of the ways
[Music]
that this works and this this um over
here at the control this
orientation on this machine because it
has the flex tool option you can you can
put an angle in here of every 15 degrees
and it'll rotate the tool to that angle
that's specified here
but that's an option as well and if you
don't have that you can only probably do
you know normal
[Music]
and reverse
on this I think I think this uh this
selection is
is uh
standard reverse but see I have what
they call well they call it a flash tool
here
and I can put an angle here if I select
this this key here
[Music]
but I'm not going to do that on this
tool of course because it's already set
up this way the tool Above This 6A
oh also on on tools on the maze act on
the integrix well on on all maze X
really they have these designations they
call ABC the letters of the alphabet you
can go all the way
to to a z I think but you can't really
uh
use certain ones because they use
they're used in programs in certain ways
like IJ and K I think or something but
all the other letters of the alphabet
you could have
that same offset like you'll notice here
I got one two three four five six seven
eight nine offsets on this one tool
right here
it goes all the way from a b c d e f g
and H
and J well the pen well I guess they let
you use J but I think they don't want I
that's why I skip h
I on that but
anyway these
are the letter designation is mostly for
using the mesotrol and you give it
priorities of which offset to use in the
mesotrol programming so if you want to
call this tool up like
um 6B in G-Code you have to put two
tools 6.02
01 is for a 02 for b o three for C and
so on you you have to use a 0.01 0.02
0.03 0.04 and so on down the alphabet
to call it a tool up like this in G-Code
and when you uh
call call the tool in G-Code or you do a
tool change to this other tool it'll
automatically rotate and Orient the
spindle and clamp it for that setup
that's that's defined in the tool setup
page here
if that makes sense so
um there's different kinds of turning
tools
for different ways of turning let me um
if I was to jog this tool back
and then index the the b-axis over here
I'm just manually indexing it
[Music]
it that's as fast as it'll index with
the doors open by the way
probably a safety feature because that
index is pretty fast when the doors are
closed in the rapid mode
[Music]
I'm going to bring this
to Y zero I'm looking at this number
right here just manually jogging it to
y0 for the time being
so I can describe something here so this
turning tool
the way this tool is defined is normally
used like this let me turn this light on
so we can kind of get
some more light here because I want to
talk about something here that happens
now you see the reason I've made this
smaller Chuck
like this
and mounted it in the larger Chuck is
because of this interference problem on
these kind of machines
see if you're down here at small
diameters you're going to be hitting
your Chuck Jaws on this if you're up
close to the Chuck like if I was going
to face down the center with this tool
you can see if as way up here with the
part very shortly sticking out of this
this Chuck I'd be hitting the Jaws
because of the width or diameter of the
spindle face here
and so I kind of get around that with
using this smaller Chuck the way I do it
but there are different ways of clearing
this on larger Chucks this is actually a
smaller Chuck than the machine came with
this is a 16 about 16 and a half inch
manual for jaw Chuck
and the Machine had a 21 inch
hydraulically operated Chuck on them on
it when I got it
but for what I do this is better because
I get a bigger spindleboard taking the
draw bar out this is another question I
get quite frequently asked why do I run
a manual for jaw Chuck
on a CNC machine
but for the kind of Machining I do
this is better because I don't do a lot
of chucking and unchucking of parts and
so I can put it in the forgot Chuck in
it and I can indicate it in very
precisely and it's not a big factor on
the type of machine work I do as far as
the the um time it takes to to manually
Chuck the part with a manual Forge off
so so that's the reason one reason I use
it and also I do some kind of work
that's a little bit off center sometimes
and
like I said before it gives me a bigger
spindle ball because if I take the draw
tube out of this machine I have a six
and five eighths spindle bore
that I could stick Parts up into on this
machine so that's good
and also uh
a manual for jaw Chuck like this will
hold the part more securely than a
hydraulic Chuck will a hydraulically
actuated chuck with spindle speed and
depending on what kind of top Jaws you
have on it will
reduce its chucking Force as the speed
increases due to centrifugal force on
the jaws and uh
part can actually come out of the Chuck
if you let it get going too fast now
this machine will only turn 1600 RPM
maximum in high range so it's not that
big of a problem but on on smaller CNC
lays where they turn five six seven
thousand RPM that can be a big issue
with a hydraulic Chuck and you have to
be aware of that
so in reality when you have something
chucked in a manual Chuck like this and
you've tighten these Jaws all down on it
there's no uh well I don't know it would
take a tremendous centrifugal force to
open those jaws and it just doesn't
happen because the machine just can't
really turn that fast in this case the
one thing I want to point out here is
when you get
if you're up close to the Chuck like
this with a turning tool like this you
see you only have a certain amount of
space unless you make a real long tool
and then that becomes a problem with
vibration and stuff
and so you can't really turn up close on
this kind of machine with this type of
tool unless the part's big in diameter
like this Chuck here is eight inches in
diameter and so it can
you can reach that and not hit the Jaws
but if you're down to a small diameter
part like this like I showed earlier you
would be hitting your jaws on the part
so
the b-axis on this machine can index and
clamp itself kind of like the the
Turning tool clamps in the spindle every
45 degrees
like that see so it actually clamps
itself in that
um angle
now this isn't the right kind of turning
tool what you would use is a turning
tool like this
in the spindle up in here and uh and you
can see well let me just I'll tell you
what let me
I have to have the the b-axis horizontal
to take the tool out
of the spindle this machine
I think it's some kind of maybe I don't
know it's a safety thing they did
[Music]
so I clamped that tool in there so this
would be this would be kind of like the
tool you would use
if you were going to turn with a bigger
Chuck
and you wanted to turn up to a close to
the Chuck you could you could get there
because the Chuck's Jaws are not going
to hit
your um
your spindle so much if if it's real
close you might put an extension on here
a short Cap Toe extension
and you could do it
so if you're doing
um see see you can see you can get right
close up to that Chuck and the Jaws are
going to clear even if you did a facing
cut all the way down the center line
with that kind of a tool
also this kind of a tool can uh as you
can see
you could actually Orient this tool
let me select this back here unclamp it
and Orient it the other direction
clamp it you can actually turn right or
left hand with this tool because this
insert is pretty much on Center Line
and you can rotate this tool back and
forth and you can also use it down
vertical if you're profiling things and
stuff like that so these tools are kind
of useful in that way
and it actually is shorter if you see
it's shorter than this tool is
and it actually has more rigidity
training like this now the b-axis also
has a curvik type coupling in its axis
and it clamps this very securely for the
Turning operations at these angles
[Music]
so so you would you could clamp it if I
Index this
it'll it'll index the V zero degrees
this is V zero and it clamps it
you probably can't hear that but I can
actually hear the the coupling clamping
and then 45
down here
and 90
and 135
and 180.
that
now if you were uh if you had a tool a
machine with a turning spindle in the
tail saw you would be uh of course
turning in these directions and you
could use that function this machine
will do it but I don't have a turning
tool over there
our turning spindle like I should say
and and so I
I don't normally do this but I can turn
this direction like this and I've done
that before
the the kind of little bit of a
disadvantage of a tool like this though
I don't know if you've noticed but you
you trade one clearance for another
clearance so
although you have more clearance here
you have less clearance on your tail
stock because your tail stock Center
will be here and the tail stock body and
you'll be colliding with the machine
here so so you have to kind of change
back and forth Tools in most cases
between a standard turning tool
or more standard I guess you might say
and one like this
I'm going to unclamp and reorient this
the way it's supposed to be for this
tool
so that's that's kind of like the 45
degree turning tool
that you can use on this type of machine
to increase your clearance
on the Chuck jaws and things like that
[Music]
so most of the Milling that you do
actually is at either on the face or on
the OD
and you can it does clamp the
v-axis
very securely at those angles and most
the time you use that when you're
Milling two as well you can do that
now I had a question
from somebody about
um using a shaping tool in the spindle
and how you can get it to do that
let me let me uh I think
my tool uh
45 let me let me go over here to the
tool setup
and look at tool 45
I think I had a
these tools defined yes so
45.03 so let me change
45.03 input this is the way you do kind
of a manual tool change on this machine
I have to close the doors
here you notice I have to push
both of these switches one on each side
to close these doors on this machine
[Music]
because you can't really do anything
with um the doors open
you'll see when it changes to this tool
it's going to highlight this offset
45C 45.03
here when it actually gets to it
right there you can see it's highlighted
it let me open the doors now I gotta to
open the doors I got to hold this down
the door unlock key and push these two
buttons simultaneously opens both doors
[Music]
we jog this tool closer over here so we
can see what's happening here
now this is the tool that I used
on the anvils
to shape the Hardy hole a square hole
first I I drilled and I milled it as
close as I could and then I shaped out
the corner square with this exact tool
right here
so you can Define
the
um a shaping tool like this let me go
down to this offset
on the control
and it's it's basically calling it a
lathe tool
here
and it has to be well it doesn't have to
be but it's better to Define it like
this because it clamps it securely
orients it clamps it and it holds the
angle very precise on clamping and if
you just use the spindle Orient there's
some give to that depending on how solid
this the motor itself can just hold it
but with this you've clamped in the
coupling and everything and it's very
securely held at a very precise angle so
if we look at if we look at the um
if we look at the offsets here we're
going to see this is at the standard
rotation orientation and this is at 90
degrees so see I've entered an angle in
for this one and that's the reverse and
the other one here is at 270 degrees
because I was I was actually
um
rotating this tool at 90 degrees and
doing Each corner of the square
all right just to demonstrate this I put
the camera inside the machine and closed
the doors because I can't
really film this too good outside
but they came in at 40 43 or 45.03 I
should say full number so we're going to
change the 45.04
if you do this it should just change the
tool I just it's just an M6 45.04
a tool change of 45.05
I'm just doing this in MDI to
demonstrate it here to you and we'll
change to 45.0
six
so this is how you can rotate this tool
all the way around and then tool change
of
45.03 back to the beginning
so that's how you can do that
in my in the case of what I was doing I
was rotating the tool and oriented and
it got clamping it
in those four angles to do each one of
the four corners of the square hole and
the Hardy hole in the Anvil
[Music]
all right
so I kind of demonstrated what I did
with that tool
now I had another question
with this on on um
a turning tool I used on the when I made
the chest pieces let me change to that I
wrote it down here it's uh
tool 2.03 we're going to do a tool
change at 2.03
that
Automotive got to close the doors again
or this actually the MDI mode
I want to talk a little bit about this
tool as well
a little bit of change to that
[Music]
foreign
I'm going to bring this tool over to
Center Line I'm looking at this number
right here the y-axis
doing this manually of course this all
happens automatically when the Tool's
actually running in the program
as zero
now let me get a light here
you can see a little bit better
let's put this uh
light here that might help a little
Maybe
I'm gonna jog this up here now this tool
I was turning
and this is just a vvmt
um boring head mounted on a Sandvik
this is really kind of like a boring bar
but it can be used like I said before as
a turning tool as anything on this type
of machine but if you were using this in
a standard lathe it would be more like
an offset boring bar
and uh I've dismounted my boring bar
head on it a bbmt head and oriented it
so it's facing down now this this has
the same geometry as that bigger OD
turning tool when it was facing the
other direction as you saw earlier
so in order to touch this tool off I
would touch my zero off
on the face of the part here my Z zero
so let me go the tool data on this tool
you can see that that would be the uh
the a dimension would be you know from
the gauge face of the spindle out to
here and then I would skim an OD and mic
it
and then set
my B Dimension here
which is the distance from the tip of
that insert to the center line of the
spindle
here which happens to be
in this case a positive direction
because like I said earlier if you
imagine you brought the center line and
the face of that spindle to the tip of
the sensor you would go upward in X and
positive and Z so that's what these
numbers are this B is an X number and
this uh a number is is a z number so you
touch the tool off like that
and the reason I was using this tool
was because on the little chess pieces
some of these angles on the back sides
of those diameters were um
our faces were steeper than this tool
could go down now this has the same
geometry
as the um OD turning tool as far as the
way the insert is located here but if I
run this um to 45 degrees well first
before I do that
notice
let's look at the position display well
I'm
precisely got a jog at the Z zero
which is here
which is this number right here
and it's on y zero X is whatever
diameter it turns it's already been
offset so I'm not going to mess with
that but
normally you would like I said you would
skim a diameter mic the diameter and
then you got to set whatever half that
radio or half that diameter the radius
the center line and it calculates that
for you the control kind of calculates
that you can say you jog the tool
straight back but don't move it in in X
and then it says how far is it away from
Center Line and it calculates the number
of the distance from Center Line plus
this distance
it subtracts it off of there so it gets
the number you want for your offset the
control will calculate that for you
but anyway what I want to show here is
now it's sitting at Z zero
and the Mesa Troll and about x one point
well
I'm I'm in the Milling mode right here
so it's a radius so let's change let's
change to the Turning mode
and now it's it's more like it should be
two two points
let me bring it right down as close as I
can to the uh
diameter this should be around two
inches okay let's just say two inches
ten thousands the
let me bring it right to two inches I
think that's two inch stock so we'll
just say two inches so if it's sitting
at Z zero and two inches
right now and you can see it's kind of
far away for this camera but I it's
right on the corner of this
face and the reason I want to show that
is
is on the mesotrol on the meso troll
control it always follows the tip of the
tool so if I were to jog this up now
and index the b-axis down to 45 which is
the way I was using this tool
and if I brought that tool back
up to two inches in x
let me precisely do it here I'm looking
at this number again right here
okay that's pretty close
and then we bring it up to zero
and z
is right there
I don't know if you can see that but
it's now
what it's using is the
imaginary point of if you
drew two lines of the radius of the
insert
and that's where it's actually lining
this offset up to
so it's it's just a you know it's like
the tip radius we insert out because
that's that's where the sharp corner
would be but what I want to point out is
how you notice that the offset
values or the values on the display
change as the tool is rotated in the
b-axis on on this machine and this in in
fact on any Mesa troll does that it
always updates whatever tool is in the
in this case the spindle buddy it can be
the turret on the turret lathe
it always updates the position of the
position display to relate to that tool
so you don't have to go to MDI and call
up the offset and do all that business
with the um
an amazing troll let me jog this up and
and you kind of see I don't know if I
was using this to cut the back diameters
or back faces on the chest pieces
because
when it's indexed at 45 the boring bar
actually has with the 35 degree Diamond
Tool like this actually has clearance on
the back faces so then
I could get
up close to the Chuck here much closer
to do those turning operations
than I could with the other tool facing
backwards and that's the reason I was
using this kind of tool for that so
you can do various things with different
tools
like I said this is this is actually a
boring bar
and normally
it would be um
it would be oriented like this when
you're using it in the horizontal
Direction
my index of B back to the horizontal
and you'd be down here boring a hole
with it of course
but I was using it the other orientation
to do the OD turning so you can do that
with this machine you can you're not
restricted to which way the tool turns
or anything like that
for um
tools on these machines because you can
index them and turn both directions or
index the b-axis and turn
with various different angles and things
with the same tool
on the on the
on the previous video on the chess
pieces I was turning the OD with it in
this relation
on on uh the queen piece I think and and
then I indexed to the 45 to turn the
back
the back turning angles
and I I think I could have done that on
the other pieces as well but I just
didn't do it for some reason
also this this had a restriction
on on
um I think it was the king or one of the
people another night maybe of it it
would hit the part because this wasn't
enough distance right here to turn the
the depth of of the night
piece I believe if I remember right it
would hit
the OD before it got down there
so anyway I don't know if this is um
[Music]
interesting or abuse I could go into
more detail there's a lot more detail
here about uh
particularly
about tool data and offsets and how this
machine on a turning tool in particular
how you can use
the the tip comp Direction now the way
the way that I do that is kind of
different because the mesotrol I should
explain this I guess if you're turning
straight in mesopro it always uses tip
comp for every tool every direction it's
turning it's compensated all the way
around the tool that's why on a turning
tool you need to make these entries on
the mesotrol like the angle of the
insert and the angle it sets in the
machine
and and uh and of course the tip radius
of the tool
and various settings like this in your
tool definition
um
it probably I don't use mesotrol a lot
there's guys here that are really good
with it and they do fantastic things but
I don't
I don't like it too much for this type
of machine
it this this
um
well the Turning part of mesotrol is
great and it works good but the Milling
part I'm not
real impressed with her I just don't
like it maybe they they hear the guys
that use it or do you know some neat
stuff with it but me I'm not really that
good with it and as far as the Milling
part of it
but on the Turning part you do have to
Define all these
these uh features of the tool
or it's not going to be able to do it
correctly but for eia type programming
or G-Code is mesotrope calls it eia
you don't have to have any of this
definition it doesn't make any
difference the only thing you really
need is a tip radius maybe depending on
what you're doing if you're turning with
tip compensation you do need this and
you need to know the direction of
compensation now because of meso troll
always turns with tip compensation it
doesn't care what the direction is it
compensates all around the tool the way
you've defined the the direction of
turning and The Cutting angles and the
angle the insert sets that and all this
stuff so it compensates everything
grooving tools you know turning tools
everything and it does it all
automatically but for for G-Code or eia
programs you do need to have a direction
of compensation for tip comp and this is
where
this took me a while to figure this out
but on the meso troll control on this
machine there because it can run eia
programs or G-Code programs it has these
offsets and you and your
you can either use these offsets
or you can use the mesotrol offsets but
the only thing I use these offsets for
because the these are designed more for
um
what would you say uh eia programs and
with eia programs you do need to have
the tip comp Direction
of the Turning tool and and so for the
first nine offsets
here I've I've put in one two three four
five six seven eight nine and that's all
I put in because you need to be able to
refer to this if you're turning in a
G-Code type of program eia G-Code
program
but there is no way if I go back to the
Mesa troll
[Music]
definition of a turning tool there is no
entry for that the way they do it except
down here and they just have this little
thing that says number
and you put in this number but this
would mean nothing if you didn't have
that other offset
having the direction on it
so I've taken the first nine offsets I
do nothing else with them but but apply
this tip comp Direction
so in this case a general outside
diameter turning tool if you're turning
just the OD of apart and you're using
tip comp it would be in the number three
Direction now I'm not going to go into a
lot of detail in this video on that
because that wasn't the purpose of this
video but there there is
um
nine different directions that tip comp
can be applied to a turning tool this is
kind of different than a Milling tool
you got cutter comp and it's just the
round diameter of the tool and that's
pretty much it on a Milling tool and it
compensates for the diameter or radius
of the tool if you will but on a turning
tool it doesn't work that way there's
nine different tip comp directions
that you apply it to
and that that deserves a whole separate
video on itself if that's of interest to
people I might make a video on that if
if there's seems to be interest in that
because that can be a little bit
confusing if you don't understand how
that works
I don't really use it a lot
it is a it is entirely necessary to use
it
depending on what you're doing with your
turning tools now mostly most cam
softwares can compensate for this tip
radius
variations on turning tools when you get
them tipped at different angles or going
up tapers or around radiuses and things
like that and I generally do that in a
cam software for the most part but if
you're
wanting to um
do a very precise thing with a turning
tool
you may need to use tip compensation or
let's let's give let me give an example
of one thing if you're doing a Groove
that has Corner radiuses broken on the
OD say it's an OD Groove and you want to
break the corners
on the between the OD of the part and
the beginning of the group you want to
deburr it basically or break the corners
and a lot of drawings have sometimes
very small dimensions for those like
three thousandths radius or five
thousands radius Corner break and
generally speaking you have to adjust
the tip radius of the tool
on the grooving tool and get those
Corner breaks just right even in the
meso troll you have to do that
it automatically does it but in eia
programming or G-Code you've got this
radius program which is little 5000
radius say and say your your tip radius
of your grooving insert isn't exactly
what they specify
or you've offset it in some way to
control your dimensions and it's just
not breaking that corner the way you
want it or it's not maybe it's not
touching it at all because it's such a
small radius so you can increase I mean
decrease you can decrease the tip radius
value in your um
awesome page and it'll cut more into the
park
on just the the radius the the diameters
will remain the same but the radius will
cut more because it thinks the tool has
a
or excuse me you got to go the other way
around you got to increase the radius so
it thinks the tool has a bigger radius
and it pushes the tool more into the
heart if that makes sense
you have to increase the radius to cut
more
it's kind of opposite of a Milling tool
where you decrease the diameter to cut
more off when you're using cutter comp
went on a lathe tool with the radius the
tip radius itself if you increase the
radius it pushes the tool more into the
part because it thinks it's got a bigger
radius on the tool
so there's things like that and
we could go into that in more more
detail but that really deserves a whole
separate program to itself I just wanted
to answer a few of these
questions I got in comments with this
program because like I said in the
beginning of the program it's it's very
difficult to
describe these kind of things
in a comment on a YouTube video and make
it understandable
[Music]
also because people have to kind of
understand
my language and they might communicate a
little bit differently than I do as far
as the the terms
that we're using and so
I got these questions and I just want to
make this video to answer some of them
so thanks for watching if if I if you
want me to go into more detail put it in
the comments on what you're interested
in and I can go into much more detail on
this there's a lot to go into and I was
trying to make this video as short as
possible if I could
[Music]